es sollte eigentlich ein historischer
tag werden heute am 29
august um 14 uhr 33 sollte die neue nasa
mondrakete abheben auftakt zur mission
atem s1 alle raumfahrt fans fieberten
auf diesen moment hin doch dann das
exakt in minute 40 vor dem zünden der
antriebe musste der staat unterbrochen
werden er ist total mission artemis 1
ein testlauf um wieder menschen auf den
mond zu schicken ein wettlauf zwischen
den usa china und anderen nationen doch
kurz vor dem start der countdown der sls
riesen rakete steht plötzlich still der
grund es
gibt ein problem beim gas der motor
entlüftung eines motors man kann dann
nicht starten da gibt es regeln und ich
denke das zeigt dass dies eine sehr
komplizierte maschine ist ein sehr
kompliziertes system
all diese dinge müssen funktionieren
man will ja nicht die kerze anzünden
bevor sie bereit ist zu brennen
der nächste mögliche start ist am
freitag um 18 uhr 48 ob dieser termin
wirklich stattfindet ist noch unklar
die schwerlast rakete sls und 98 meter
hoch soll die raumkapsel orion ins all
bringen an bord sind zwei puppen an
ihnen wird eine schutzweste gegen
gefährliche weltraum strahlung speziell
für den weiblichen körper getestet
außerdem werden 10 schuhkarton große
satelliten ausgesetzt die mission
artemis 1 sieht wie folgt aus zuerst
umrundet die rakete die erde um dann
weiter zum mond zu fliegen auf dem weg
zum erdtrabanten wird dann das
raumschiff orion abgetrennt nach dem
erreichen des mondes soll dieser von
orion mehrfach umrundet werden nach 18
tagen sollen die mond laufbahn wieder
verlassen und zur erde zurückkehren beim
wettlauf zum mond geht es den
amerikanern und anderen ländern um
mögliche seltene erden auf dem
erdtrabanten und darum diesen als
ausgangspunkt für künftige mars
missionen zu nutzen china etwa plant in
zukunft eine permanente mondstation die
aktuelle mission findet ohne menschen
statt
2025 sollen dann zum ersten mal wieder
menschen den mond betreten
zuletzt geschah das vor 50 jahren
1972 ab 2025 bis 2030 sind dann auch
europäer mit dabei nun bleibt aber erst
einmal abzuwarten ob beim nächsten start
alles klappt ja und ich freue mich jetzt
mit alexander gerst sprechen zu können
er gehört seit 2009 dem europäischen
astronautenkorps an 2014 reist er als
elfter deutscher ins all und weil der
dritte deutsche raumfahrer auf der iss
hatte dort sogar als erster deutscher
das kommando so hier große luke
lobhudelei von mir jetzt vielen dank
dass sie dabei sind herrn erst einmal
die frage zum einstieg oder minder in
letzter minute also der startabbruch
können sie uns mal den einfachen worten
erklären was da jetzt genau kaputt war
schönen guten abend ja das ist
tatsächlich so bei einem testflug der
weiß man nie was dabei rauskommt in
diesem fall war es so sie haben sich
schon gesagt und ihren beitrag ungefähr
eine stunde vor dem start hat man
entdeckt das ist ein kleines problem gab
mit einem entlüftungsventil an einem der
zwei werke das ist dafür da um das
triebwerk auch schnell bestimmte
temperatur zu kühlen die es braucht nur
den status muss ganz präzise geregelt
werden bevor die triebwerke gezündet
werden dürfen und eines dieser
ventile hat wohl erklärte dass gerade
ein kleines problem damit und damit
konnte man das triebwerk nicht
unterkühlen und dann hat man gesagt das
ist jetzt riskiert ist im festbuch da
muss man konservativ sein dann
halten wir den katern anja stoppen den
start für heute schauen uns das problem
an und dann entscheiden wie es
weitergeht solche starts sind ja immer
mit wahnsinnig viel spannung verbunden
alle fiebern irgendwie daraufhin an
diesem tag auf diesen tag der tage wie
üblich ist es dass so was dann wirklich
tatsächlich kurz vorher abgebrochen wird
dank natürlich schon auch so auch bei
dem space shuttle starts here von
travelers los die haben viele
abhängigkeiten da muss alles passen das
wetter die technik und so weiter und das
heißt was von anfang an klar ist dass
sein kann dass saisonstart verschoben
das ist jetzt noch mal nochmal
spezieller der fall weil die artemis ein
paket das ja wirklich die den beginn
einer neuen ära der weltraumfahrt das
ist eine rakete mit dem raumschiff um
daraus das von den usa und europa gebaut
wurden ist also das gemeinschaftsprojekt
zwischen der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa und nasa das
als auch hart was ja in deutschland
gebaut worden das heißt wir uns das ein
wichtiges projekt und da will man
natürlich sicher gehen gerade bei diesem
letzten test schlug in der neuen
konfiguration also alles an diesem
system das ist brandneu das ist noch nie
so geflogen da will man natürlich
vorsichtig sein vor allem weil auf dem
nächsten flug dann das ehrlich menschen
fliegen sollen mit dem mond um den mond
herum und dann wieder zurück und da muss
man natürlich auch alles essen deswegen
war das heute eine richtige entscheidung
natürlich ist man immer so ein bisschen
enttäuscht wenn man auf den start
warteten waren alle meine kolleginnen
und kollegen und ich waren alle die
ganze nacht über auf den beinamen
interviews gegeben haben den technikern
ingenieuren gesprochen und darauf
hingefiebert und dann kurz davor wenn es
ausfällt zweiten mal ein bisschen
enttäuscht aber man muss daran denken
das ist genauso gedacht also s-bahn ist
dafür da dass man herausfindet was
vielleicht gehen kann in dem fall ich
glaube nicht dass es ein großes problem
ist ehrlich gesagt dass wir sehen wenn
die nasa und die esa zusammen eine
pressekonferenz geben werde ungefähr
eine stunde von jetzt an die mission
steens besprechen das gerade was die
optionen sind und dann vielleicht gibt
es eine startmöglichkeit nächsten
freitag am zweiten september aber es war
nicht ganz klar auf die wagen wird ob
man noch ein bisschen mehr wollte herr
gäste sprachen gerade von einer neuen
ära ich habe in meiner anmoderation von
einem historischen tag gesprochen ein
historischer schritt nicht nur wegen der
zusammenarbeit aber was mich wirklich
interessiert wie nah kommen wir mit
dieser mission dem mars
gibt in richtung mars oder erst mal geht
es jetzt für ich zum mond aber
das ist natürlich immer auch die
möglichkeit weiter raus dermaßen
tatsächlich bei uns ein ganz großes ziel
da und dahin fliegen müssen noch ein
bisschen was lernen wir haben in den
letzten 20 jahren schon viel und der iss
der internationalen raumstation gelernt
und wie man im weltraum erlebt wie man
als mensch sein kann die man ressourcen
dürften gar nicht ob selbst ein jahr
darum verbrachte ich habe gemerkt dass
man als mensch eigentlich ganz gut im
bett noch ein ebenfalls aber das ist
noch relativ lange ältere hat immer
hilfe von der bodenstation wenn wir zum
mond fliegen wird das ganze schon echt
viel schwieriger ist es dauert länger um
ihn zukommen da kann man nicht mal so
einfach kurz etwas nachgestellt werden
was ausgeht und ja da lernt man viel
darüber wie es ist im weltraum zu leben
und das braucht man dann weiter zum mars
fliegen aber der mond ist nicht nur ein
zwischenziel der mond ist er extrem im
sand wissenschaftlich der muss ja
wahrscheinlich aus der erde heraus
entstanden wir wissen dass noch nicht
was so genau weil wir bisher nur ein
paar kleine auch gesammelt hat eine
apollo mission aber eigentlich machen
dass ihr logisch gesehen ich sehr
interessant hier gegen den
den südpol das bin ich als geophysiker
natürlich sehr spannend da ist viel
älter ist als auch wasser im gestein und
ihrer kunden unsere kosmische umgebung
das ist sehr wichtig für uns und
gleichzeitig bei diesem
gemeinschaftsprojekt schauen darauf dass
die europäische industrie und die
deutschen auch mit dabei ist mit freude
daran bei ist eine partnerschaft mit der
nasa ist ein großartiges kompliment ist
wirklich brauchen damals dass wir auf
den tischen partie sehr wichtigen
missionen gelassen wurde und das zeigt
dass wir als partner im weltraum eben
nicht mehr juniorpartner sind wie die
esa das vor irgendeiner jahren war dass
wir aufgewachsen sind es gleichwertige
partner und deswegen geht jetzt darum
dass wir da dranbleiben dass wir das
nicht außen vor lassen dass wir uns
nicht auf den lorbeeren aus und sind
dass wir auch neue projekte als europäer
und europäerinnen auf den weg bringen
und dann attraktives design
wenn es dann vielleicht geht ja wir sind
auf jeden fall gespannt ob es dann beim
nächsten mal klappen wird wir drücken
die daumen auch für alle raumfahrtfans
und sind natürlich hier wieder live
dabei vielen dank für das gespräch
alles ist gut so
[Musik]